you are a full-fledged rapper now are
you owning that title honestly yes I
just I've always wanted to be a musician
I love writing music and I love like
being able to just spit over it bees
alright honestly rapping des like take
the cake because it's kind of like
mixing poetry with singing and
delivering and clever wordplay like it's
just like mixing a lot of things I like
together
that's drag race alum Asia taking over
the rap game and reclaiming their voice
with the new album box office why the
name box office well I have a very big
fascination with just media movies
television amps it's the story of my
life as told through themes of movies
and shows it's truly telling a story
about my rebirth me coming into the
spotlight owning it my troubles
what has hurt me and what has given me
life and ending it with overcoming
everything and it's kind of like a plot
from a movie you have a favorite song on
box office oh boy so my favorite track
on box office honestly is a track 15
it's Kill Bill and I think it's because
one of the reoccurring themes in my life
has been resilience cuz that's always
been that story of everything says no
but I'm like yes yes don't regret it fix
your face
wait wait matter of fact Annie fix your
whole life before you try again get it
so safe to say you listen to box office
all the tracks through you kind of know
the story of Asha by the end of it yes I
definitely wanted to share themes that
I've gone through my life especially I
think when the listener listens to
Anarchy they'll learn a lot about me how
would you say the odds are we here on
the record of the Asha who's touring now
is different from the Asha we last saw
on Drag Race when you see me in person
or when you hear the record you're
hearing my edit my perspective this is
my story told through my eyes and when
you meet me in person you get to meet me
like it's like me me it's not someone on
TV if for me a drag has sort of become
more of a vehicle of expression instead
of a primary art type I look at drag as
more of just like expressing myself and
the music is the actual art for me if
you are someone who's a drag artist
there's an expectation that your art
especially if it's music is going to be
written off as some sort of comical
thing or it's just not gonna be taken
seriously if people take a closer look
we've been surrounded by drag queens in
the mainstream for ever Prince yeah
David Bowie Lady Gaga Nicki Minaj like
cardi B like these are people they wear
the same lace fronts they wear the same
costumes they're obsessed with MU glare
and why a cell and they like that's what
they're doing so true it's the same
thing so like you know let's call a
spade a spade they're doing that that's
what I'm doing
get on top of me but you will never do
it you are just me the themes on these
songs there's a lot of message it seems
like to the people who doubted you to
the haters are you speaking to people in
particular are these more broad messages
I kind of like the idea of interpret the
message yourself because it's like okay
well if you feel like I'm talking about
you then I probably had another theme on
the record seems to be freedom yes what
does freedom mean to you freedom to me
is it's just something I've always
wanted freedom is is really finding your
worth it's finding out and realizing
that no matter what anybody says you are
valid person and you are worthy of
happiness just contentment do you feel
free and content now I feel very free in
content and I know that there's a lot of
people out there that don't like that
that's what makes it even better
[Music]